have you seen this man probably this is
one of the most famous police sketches
ever made and it's supposed to be this
guy Ted kazinski aka the unibomber an
American Terrorist who mailed homemade
explosives across the country for almost
20 years obviously the sketch artist
didn't have much to work with and the
unibomber left no fingerprints or DNA so
how was he finally caught Linguistics
I'm Erica brazowski PhD and this is
other words
[Music]
other
words when the unibomber sent a 35,000
word manifesto to the newspapers the FBI
had forensic linguists James Fitzgerald
and Roger Choy examine it for language
Clues they found some outdated
terminologies like Broad and chick that
weren't likely to come from a woman or a
young person Arcane words like omic and
chical suggested a high level of
education and they knew that odd
spellings like willfully and clue were
briefly popular in the Chicago area in
the 40s and 50s in 1995 Linda Patrick
was reading the manifesto in the
Washington Post and found it
disturbingly familiar she asked her
husband David to take a look and he
instantly recognized some of the phrases
from letters his brother had written to
newspapers at the time the FBI was
receiving thousands of tips but when
they heard that David's brother was a
highly educated middle-aged man from the
Chicago area it piqued their interest
Fitzgerald and shy compared the letters
David supplied them with the manifesto
and concluded that unless it was an
elaborate hoax this had to be their man
shortly thereafter the FBI raided an
isolated cabin in the Montana Wilderness
where they found Ted kazinski along with
bomb making materials and an original
copy of the
manifesto in a way we are all forensic
linguists have you ever reread a
friend's text trying to deduce why
they're really skipping your party have
you ever poured over a warranty before
making a big purchase or stared at
graffiti on a bathroom wall trying to
guess what Jesse could have done to get
called out like that in all of these
cases you're analyzing linguistic Clues
like word choice grammar and punctuation
to dig for hidden meaning but the term
forensic Linguistics didn't exist until
the 1960s when s just linguist Yan
sparik reexamined a controversial murder
case through a linguistic lens in 1949 a
Welshman named Timothy Evans confessed
to the Strangling of his wife and baby
daughter in a series of strangely
contradictory statements 3 years after
his conviction and hanging it was
discovered that Evans downstairs
neighbor a man named John Christie was
actually a serial killer and the real
murderer of Evans wife and daughter why
would Evans confess to something he
didn't do since he was was functionally
illiterate all his statements had been
dictated to police investigators
totaling almost 5,000 words spart vict
analyzed the text using several metrics
like the frequency of different types of
grammatical Clauses what he found was
that whenever the statements veered into
fantasy a different voice seemed to take
over maybe Evans changed his speaking
style when he lied or maybe the
dictating officer took some creative
Liberties this kind of analysis known as
stylometry assumes that each of us has
our own idict a unique way of speaking
that can be used like a fingerprint to
identify us your idect includes obvious
things like vocabulary and pronunciation
but also subtle syntactic habits do you
prefer active voice or passive voice do
you tend to put adverbial Clauses before
or after the main Clause you may not
notice these habits but a forensic
linguist might one of the key methods of
stylometry is categorizing words and
Counting them people who use more nouns
articles and prepositions tend to be
more rational and analytic while those
who favor verbs adverbs and pronouns are
more Dynamic and emotional you can also
put words into broad thematic categories
like family religion sensuality and
death in 2015 social psychologist Ryan L
Boyd and linguist James W pennebaker
used this word counting method to
analyze Shakespeare's plays and build a
psychological profile much like an FBI
agent would for a criminal they compared
it to the text of a play with disputed
authorship called double falsehood and
found that Shakespeare was the most
likely author of the first three acts
with his frequent collaborator John
Fletcher writing the last two stylometry
has been used to identify modern authors
as well it's how we know that the
zapatista military leader subcomandante
Marcos is actually the respected writer
Rafael Sebastian guen viente it's how
journalist Joe kleene was outed as the
anonymous author of the political novel
primary colors and how who dribe Robert
galbreth was revealed to be a pseudonym
for Hogwarts billionaire JK Rowling but
authorship attribution is a lot easier
when you have a big body of texts to
analyze known as a corpus in criminal
investigations it's not every day that
the perpetrator sends you a 35,000 word
manifesto smooth mov T most of the time
you're working with much smaller samples
take the 1996 murder of 6-year-old
pageant Queen John Benet Ramsay even
before her body was discovered in the
basement of the family home
investigators already thought that there
was something hinky about the ransom
note left behind for one thing it was
about three times longer than an average
Ransom note with phrases lifted right
out of popular action movies do not
attempt to grow a brain the letter also
contains several instances of what
linguists call adversarial stylometry
when someone deliberately tries to
obscure their writing style like
misspelling simple words or claiming to
be foreign which is not an agitate that
people often used to describe themselves
linguists are also called in to analyze
letters sent to the police by supposed
serial killers like the Zodiac Killer
and the Beltway Sniper in 2018 a
forensic linguist from the University of
Manchester used modern techniques to
analyze the letter sent to London Police
in 1888 by someone claiming to be Jack
the Ripper not only did he confirm that
the first two letters were written by
the same person but also found a
potential connection with a third letter
that was long thought to beat a hoax
written by someone from the central news
agency to boost newspaper sales this
might mean that all the letters were
hoaxes that the real killer never wrote
to the police at all and never named
himself Jack the Ripper in such cases
the Corpus is so small that they can
only make guesses about the type of
person who wrote them rather than match
it to a specific author but that may be
changing thanks to technology ology in
the era of social media each one of us
has an extensive Corpus of posts tweets
and comments that can be mined to build
an ID lectic profile and artificial
intelligence can analyze that corpus
with stunning accuracy after all that's
exactly what these algorithms were
designed to do find patterns and
language but the complexity of AI can
also limit its usefulness in forensic
Linguistics the most powerful systems
are typically unsupervised meaning their
own programmers don't know how they
reach their conclusions they find
patterns in language so obscure that a
professional linguist would have trouble
understanding it let alone a jury of lay
people and that does not fly in a court
of law you can't have a computer on the
witness and just say trust me he's your
guy perhaps the day will come when AI
evidence is as accepted and normalized
as DNA evidence but until then juries
can't convict someone based on the word
of an algorithm unless we Outsource jury
duty to AI as well and I'm terrified to
think how many people would be okay with
that for now human linguists still have
a place in courtrooms and not just to
introduce evidence they help lawyers
fine-tune their arguments parse
complicated statements with disputed
meanings monitor police interrogation
tactics and even ensure that
non-english-speaking defendants are
interpreted fairly and accurately the
fact that we all have our own unique way
of speaking is a beautiful thing it's at
the core of personal expression and
contributes the wonderful tapestry of
language but it also means that no form
of expression can be 100% Anonymous as
the famous Miranda warning goes anything
you say can and will be used against you
in a court of
law sty stylometry stylometry yeah Style
Style every time I see it feels weird
stylometry Yan JN Yan yanic oh did you
hear me say often often with a
t